welcome to holy smokes the spectators
religion podcast
i'm damian thompson
yesterday's announcement by boris
johnson of new corona virus restrictions
which limit the number of people who can
attend weddings to
15 and funerals to 30
was predictably vigorously welcomed
by the archbishop of canterbury and
other bishops
my own reaction was what on earth are
they welcoming
these restrictions will affect not only
weddings and funerals
but will encourage the churches to
further tighten freedom of worship
something they've been doing with
tremendous and baffling vigor
ever since the pandemic began i spoke to
dr gavin ashington
holy smokes resident expert on church
affairs
about what this means for both the
church of england
and the catholic church in this country
both of which are make no mistake about
it in an exceptionally
fragile state so gavin when
i read of these new restrictions on
churches weddings back to 15 people
funerals 30 people these strange
arbitrary numbers
i suddenly had a sinking feeling and a
rather melodramatic response i suppose
which is it's all over
all over for the churches that is rather
than christianity
because i've watched the churches
both anglican and catholic not exactly
struggle to recover from the
restrictions that have been placed upon
them but
go along meekly or even enthusiastically
with the restrictions
we know that people have not returned to
church in anything like the numbers that
they were attending before
and now it seems as if
those bishops of both churches who have
been so
perversely enthusiastic about
embracing restrictions on their own
freedom of worship
almost as if it's their own mission now
have an excuse simply to bolt the doors
again
i don't mean that we'll necessarily go
back to a situation where
you know there are no public masses or
no public acts of anglican worship
but the thumb screws will be tightened
even further clergy will be strongly
dissuaded from
taking any initiatives that might
conceivably go against the
rather shaky coveted embraced by the
government
and institutional decline is gathering
pace
to the point where i'm not sure that
christianity in its current organized
form
is going to be sustainable after 2020.
what do you think one of the first
things that all
first term students of the greek new
testament get taught is that the word
crisis in greek
doesn't just mean a crisis it also
stands for a moment of judgment
and so although what you've said sounds
very dramatic and sad and rather rather
threatening i think and some people
listening will think
gosh if damien's right we're in for a
very bad time
an understanding of the history of the
church teaches us that whenever a crisis
comes that part of the church which
isn't up to the job
folds away comes under judgment dries up
and a renewed church comes as a response
to the judgment to the crisis so
i think the elements we can identify
here are first of all
why is the bureaucratic response what it
is why are the bishops
and the administrators of the is
behaving in
such a compliant way in this particular
culture
and that throws up the question about
the church's self-understanding
in most of the previous centuries the
church has said
that eternal life matters much more than
this life i've never forgotten the
excitement
as a 12 year old listening to a man for
all seasons when
saint thomas more says to richard rich
richard it it says somewhere what does
it profit a man
to gain the whole world but lose his
soul but but but for wales rich he says
who sold his soul
to become chancellor of wales you don't
hear
the church saying to the world today to
our society
look you might live uh one year five
years
10 years 30 years longer in this body
but the thing you really need to worry
about is whether you go to hell
purgatory or heaven and
what happens when you stand in judgment
now that's been completely missing from
the church's
self-understanding and and public
pronouncements so maybe
at this point the church is being
invited to choose between being an
arm of the health and safety culture
offering a slap of spirituality to
people's
self-becoming or whether it's going to
be faithful to
what jesus taught and practiced and to
what the church was always aspired to
down through the ages so here we have a
moment of crisis
a moment of judgment at the church i
think will divide
well christians may indeed face that
sort of choice
do we go along with the civil
authorities and
unfortunately the bishops seem to be
part of the civil authorities these days
or do we find our own route to revival
the difficulty is that you were
mentioning times in the past when the
church has renewed itself but those were
in societies where most people were
believers anyway
so the process of renewal was something
much more natural than it would be today
when a minority of people hold anything
resembling conventional
orthodox supernatural beliefs so i think
it'd be much
more difficult for a revived
christianity
to gain the audience it needs
gosh you know i really don't agree with
you at all that the details are are
wholly different in our society but i
think that the paradigmatic patterns are
the same
so it it always comes down to
are you going to prioritize the the
immediate
values of the society or the power
structures you live in
or where they come into conflict with
the teachings of the gospel are you
going to prioritize those
i mean for example at the moment isn't
it funny how the church for the last 50
years has prided itself on
speaking truth to power so when it comes
to racism or economic equality
our right on leaders have stood up and
have been very happy to speak out
politically to challenge the status quo
you couldn't have
a more pregnant moment for speaking
truth to power
when the whole scientific community is
completely itself divided
on what this virus means what it's going
to do what's going to happen
what are sensible and what are not
sensible proportions
and you would think at this point the
church might say actually there are two
views one is very much not proven and
the other gives more freedom to the
human individual
in the face of state control we're going
to opt for the one
that prioritizes the sanctity of
anthropology so to speak
but not at all it's sided completely
with a health and safety culture
of part of the scientific community so i
don't think that
the challenge it faces today in deciding
what its
value system is going to be is is
different in principle
to any of the other moments where
there's been a social political
historical crisis and where essentially
you have
if you like the will to power uh saying
doing demanding one thing
and the church doing another i mean you
could go straight back to bonhoeffer and
and germany in 1930 it's it's the same
principle
i think if we examine church history we
we'd find that the paradigm is always
the same
but the point i was making is that while
it's certainly possible for the church
to
challenge the authorities and
for people to join the church in its
resistance to ridiculous rules
what you don't have is a theological
consensus
either in society or actually even among
churchgoers of the sort that might build
a renewed orthodox christianity
because every opinion poll carried out
for decades
shows that even the opinions of
churchgoers are remarkably sort of
negotiable and
flexible and not terribly rooted in the
nike and creed
yeah well i agree with that i mean
you're quite right you've described the
nature of the current crisis
which is that for um for a very long
time the theology of modernism the
increasing secularization of christian
categories the diminishment of
metaphysics the increase of political
priorities
all these things have denuded
christianity of
its essential character and we have a
very much
weakened laity very much weakened
clergy and episcopate who have
been trained to be secularized and it's
going to be a huge shock i mean if you
were to say
to any of the bishops or the priests who
are who are taking responsibility for
decisions today what are you going to do
are you going to put health and safety
culture first of all
and and the the witty boris johnson
approach to the science first
or are you going to put the priority of
the mass and of prayer
and a meeting together in a sane and
safe way
as christians and the other half of the
scientific consensus 95 are going with
the health and safety culture and with
the
trust of government advice and that
seems to me to be
demonstrating exactly what you said we
have a crisis of the deepest
proportions and it's ever it's got to do
with
any sense of the priority of the
supernatural any sense of the priority
of heaven and hell
and of judgment and a willing and loving
carelessness
with our mortality of course we don't
have the right to be careless with other
people's mortality
but we we're called to be careless with
our own
if it's in the service of the gospel let
me tell you a little story which it
might indicate that there is a way
forward
for enterprising parishes
of whatever denomination but i wouldn't
want to extrapolate from that
a message that the crisis is not as
severe as it is because i think it's of
unimaginable proportions but the church
opposite me has
reacted to covid in a very unusual way
it's a catholic church
and what it's done is that from eight
o'clock in the morning to 6
30 in the evening every single week day
it has exposition of the blessed
sacrament and the doors wide open and
this has been
drawing people into the church in a way
that i haven't seen in the 20 years that
i've lived opposite it
and i felt not only encouraged
by this but i have been physically drawn
into the church
simply by walking past and seeing what
catholics believe is
the living god on the altar and it
almost feels rude not to go in
and i hugely admire the parish priests
and the other priests and the
church community for taking that step
but they've had to take
that step in the knowledge that
their diocese doesn't really approve
and i almost get a
thing with of an underground church when
i visit
a number of parishes amen among a
minority of parishes
that have responded creatively
to this unanticipated and shocking
challenge
and i use this phrase underground church
we hear an awful lot about the
underground church in china which has
been so
disgustingly betrayed by pope francis
i'm beginning to wonder if we're not
entering a period where
maybe it's time for orthodox
christianity to
in a sense go underground
that is remove itself insofar as is
theologically possible
from the oversight of the bishops who
are destroying it
in league with secular authorities
this strikes a very strong chord with me
in in the early 1980s one of the things
i did was to carry
theological books in suitcases into
prague
in order to help the catholic
underground church prepare and ordain
priests and
eliot has this wonderful phrase in the
end is our beginning
the beginning is our end i'm surprised
to discover that
that we're faced with the prospect of
con even considering the existence
of an underground church at this stage
but but having said that
um as a matter of personal resonance
i think you're right and what we're
faced with is practice and principle now
in a way maybe that the worst of the
crisis in practice is behind us
the thing that broke my heart and
profoundly offended me was the churches
being
being closed and the mass well the mass
continued in catholic churches behind
closed doors thank god
but but it didn't continue in anglican
churches to
i think their their their serious
uh their serious disadvantage but so
long as the churches
the doors stay open and the mass is
continued and the blessed sacrament is
exposed then the crisis of practice may
be over but
the crisis of principle remains um the
church is not
is still not yet convinced that the
immortal the supernatural
the eternal take priority over the
temporal
uh and the mortal and it could very well
be actually that if one was a bishop or
a priest
this terrible moment in our social
life societal life together is exactly
one where we can begin to talk more
freely about what christianity
really is it it provides in an
atmosphere of
horrible fear that the pandemic has
developed and i have to say the
government is
is exacerbating and encouraging
christianity provides the most
wonderful reassurance and peace
in the face of this terrible existential
threat so
so one of the first things we can do is
say to have to a society that's becoming
increasingly paranoid and
anxious you don't have to be we have a
different understanding
of the human task so again i think the
churches will divide into those that
respond
to the crisis and the judgment by
getting closer to the gospel and our
roots
and those that remain content to be part
of a health and safety culture and to be
closed down
as being simply a a religious
recreational arm of the state
to which nobody attaches much importance
but the problem is gavin that they will
divide as you rightly say
down the middle of great historic
denominations which by the way was
something predicted by the great
american sociologist james davidson
hunter in his 1990 book
cultural wars that the lines of division
would run
within denominations rather than between
them
and so what you would have in effect in
the catholic and ancient churches are
those parishes which
operate what i would call an underground
policy and those
that go along with managed decline and
by underground i don't
really mean the catacombs don't forget
that in china the underground church has
worshipped
openly for quite a long time it's just
that they do so in the face of
terrible disapproval and all sorts of
horrible sanctions which are now
tragically endorsed by the vatican we
have talked in the past often
reasons about the catholic church i
would like to know more about the church
of england
in which you were a clergyman for many
years
with which you remain on good terms and
i know you're very friendly with
lots of you know well-connected vicars
and
other quite senior church officials who
have been telling you
what the reality is like on the ground
and i wonder if you could just spell it
out for me
yes i mean if i first i can say that
isn't it interesting that the
sociological analysis matches the
eschatological one so that
within catholic spirituality the uh the
the same message for example through the
marian
uh visitations has come as the one
provided by the sociologists
so we ought to take we ought to take
note and that is that the way in which
the church is going to divide is going
to be along different lines i think
the reason why that's so difficult to
understand is um our minds are set
retrospectively
in the in the historic framework left to
us by the reformation which makes us
think in terms of
catholic and protestant but you quite
rightly
say that there's a different division
that we have to face now and i think
it's probably between the secular and
the spiritual between the supernatural
and the material and so inevitably
that split is going to divide the
catholic church in one particular way in
the anglica church in one particular way
i'm not sure how the rest of the
protestant churches are going to manage
it because they're kind of predicated
on an accommodation with with a secular
non-supernatural view of the world but
but the bit will affect the pentecostals
and so
you're right each major church body will
find itself being
divided along this line which i think is
probably best described as
as a secular versus a supernatural it's
all about metaphysics
in in the church of england
the problem is there's been such a
change that the latest
there were there were two releases of of
the metaphysical
view i suppose well there have been
three haven't there's been the wesleyan
revival
the anglo-catholic revival tractarians
and then the charismatic revival and
each one of them has
has involved exactly what we're talking
about now this injection of the
supernatural is
calling back to to radical to
christianity to the roots
the trouble is they've all died down in
the church of england now the the
charismatic movement has been
domesticated and somewhat um
not exactly ridiculed but but certainly
tamed
uh the anglo-catholic movement in the
church of england is
well i i don't want i i i won't say
anything about it because
my friends are still there and and i i
would find it difficult
to to to maintain the required levels of
politeness
well let me perhaps say what's up the
back of your mind which is that the
anglo-catholic movement is
dead it turned off its toes quite a long
time ago it sacrificed its principles
and is as thoroughly protestant as saint
helens bishops gate or
any other hardline protestant part of
the church of england but that's
my personal view well i've been
reflecting on this
in the last few months in particular and
i i think it's very difficult
to describe yourself either adjectivally
or as a noun as being catholic
if you if you continue to refuse
reconciliation
with the pope and the mother church um
i mean you know you can't be catholic if
you do
that so when one i think one has to find
a different
a different uh description of it and the
evangelical group of course
in a very interesting way over the last
30 years has been seduced by
secularism it's been extraordinary to
watch it uh there was a great revival in
the 1960s on the back of billy graham
and then
in the 70s with john stott and david
watson uh
and to some extent americans like like
like wimber came over and strengthened
it
festivals like greenbelt um straddled
a number of interest groups and then
since the 1980s
i think partly because there is no
magisterium there is no agreed
means of finding an authority to
challenge
the permanent magnetic pool for
accommodation with secular society
it has become more secular and bought
entirely this is justin will be brought
entirely
into the sexualized and secularized
interpretation of
of the human condition so the trouble is
there isn't any
there is no platform within the church
of england
for um the renewal of the supernatural
to be built upon or there is no seedbed
whichever metaphor you want to use and
in that sense
i'm terribly sorry to say but i mean i
look at it and i wonder
how could it be reformed and revived how
can a new supernaturalism take root
when none of the areas in which it's
happened in the past
will accommodate it anymore well let me
come to the defense of the church of
england for a bit and say that in my
opinion there are
evangelical churches that vigorously
and imaginatively preach the gospel such
as holy trinity brompton and i think one
of the tragedies is that justin welby
who is nurtured in that church
has not carried forward its message into
lambda palace
even if you don't find its churchmanship
appealing
i have seen nikki gumble and that
congregation
close up and i can see that it is
vibrant and one of the last churches i
think to wither
in this crisis but there are also lots
of
very very good christians not especially
dogmatic both
lay and clergy in the church of england
who are finding themselves utterly
defeated by
the awful confluence of the
financial crisis already facing the
church of england
and welby's managerial determination
to shut down debate and shut down
parishes
i wonder if you just give me a picture
of what life is going to be
like for the average church of england
clergymen or
clergy woman in the coming years
can the infrastructure be sustained yes
when you quite rightly have brought me
from
from being critical about categories to
be to being reminded about the
heroism and the quality of many people
and so thank you for doing that
because it might be thought that because
i didn't say it
i don't share your views entirely i do
there's no doubt at all that within the
church of england there are if you like
islands of holiness commitment
imagination and
and heroism the problem is and this is
what what i was trying to get to with
the categories
is there is no means of defending them
or organizing them or binding together
in the form of a movement and so some of
them will survive
as marvelous congregationalist examples
but here's the paradox the only way that
they can they can survive is by
following a congregationalist model
in an episcopal church so someone will
indeed survive you're quite right
and one hopes that as many as possible
can and will
however the more supernatural they are
the more hostility
they they provoke from the bureaucratic
secularists
who run the church and to organize the
finances i think the picture that's
beginning to emerge
is that my my well-placed friends tell
me that
a third of the cathedrals are teething
on bankruptcy
another third have half a dozen years of
solvency and not much
not obvious ways of turning around and
the final third are very well endowed
and will survive
almost anything that the economy throws
at them in churches
the pattern for the church of england
now that is ordained women is
to find that it's very reliant on
a noble army of middle-aged part-time
women who take some responsibility for
allowing small beleaguered communities
to take over but that's that's a
pretty restricted vision of church and
what it's meant to be and so
the paris structure in the church of
england is going to disappear very
quickly because the money simply isn't
there
and the real decision that we have to be
made by so many dioceses is
do we declare this church a church that
is open twice a year for
harvest festivals and christmas or do we
close it down
and mothball it or sell it i think given
the demographics of
the fact that the average age is about
70 now
and there's a large group of clergy
about
a third i think are due to retire round
about now
that it's simply run out of people and
money
and time what will be left will be the
icing on the cake some of the the abbeys
some pools
some of the cathedrals certainly the
bureaucracy who've got a very
rich cushion in terms of church
commissioner's money
to rely on to keep them going a bit like
police stations in the community or some
gp surgeries when you look for a local
expression
somewhere near you'd have access to it
may be very thin on the ground indeed
you use the word congregationalism and i
think it's an absolutely crucial concept
right now
the catholic and anglican churches were
not congregationalists
in other words parishes were not
self-sustaining
units who operated independently of the
rest of the church
to an extent i think the catholic church
too faces
what you might call the
congregationalist threat or even
perhaps a congregationalist opportunity
in that
i think only successful parishes will
survive and by successful i mean those
that
are run by priests who have a
vision and the cultural and imaginative
resources to communicate it
to other people now these churches are
pretty
thin on the ground i'm lucky in london
that there are a very significant number
of them and i live
opposite one but for example my sister
has the misfortune to live in the
catholic parish where
the priest in addition to not taking the
slightest interest in her
health crisis for which i can never
forgive him has simply posted these
miserable depressing lists of coveted
restrictions
on the front of the church and mass
there and in
many other churches it's almost like
a crime scene bits of the church are
cordoned off
and actually that extends to westminster
cathedral as well which i think is a
very very badly run
cathedral indeed and you can see its
authority
bleeding away in the direction of the
brampton oratory all the time
but that's open just for you know two
and a half hours a day according to one
priest
was telling me and there's nobody there
it's driving away people so it's not
congregationalist
it's losing its identity of course
helping that along by
dismantling the choir so that even in
the catholic church
it will require a sort of
congregationalist impulse
for the body to survive and that
is not the church that we have known for
the last 1500 years
is it i think what you're doing is
you're you're i mean
you're describing the bad bit of the
catholic church you just described
is that part which has most accommodated
itself
to the the thrust of vatican ii now my
vatican ii means
many different things and i don't want
to slip into the to obvious blunder of
being for or against it that would be
much too clumsy but
one of the things that is it is evident
is that the traditional catholic
movement
is the one movement that is attracting
young people
the latin mass turns out to be a very
significant magnet
a rediscovery of the transcendent the
supernatural
the historic character of the church
seems to have some magnetic
draw to a society that has been
wholly starved of these things now i
don't know whether that will be enough
to revive the whole catholic church
but there's no doubt at all that it's
one area of serious
growth and interest and so in that sense
i think that's the answer to your
your anxiety about congregationalism my
sense is
where the catholic church rediscovers
itself
in its most authentic and profound
embodiment both liturgically and
aesthetically
it will find itself being renewed
it's exactly the opposite it's exactly
where you try and
implement a secularized view of the
church that you end up by
by putting together a bunch of
sociological clubs
trying to you know make nice and be
friendly but the fact is the church has
never been attractive as a club
uh other clubs amateur opera societies
bowling clubs
have always done it much better than the
church has done the church
is a place where people get together to
meet and love one another
but primarily in the shadow of prayer
and worship which comes first
so i think where the catholic church
discovers a renewed transcendence
there it becomes most truly itself and
we'll have the greatest
pull i do think that what you say about
the catholic church applies
to a degree to the church of england as
well the problem is
that these revived parishes
which will not i think be geographical
parishes but rather gathered
congregations
in other words people will travel to a
church that they like
rather than the church that happens to
be around the corner which they're
supposed to attend
these revived churches
could find themselves subjected to a
degree of intimidation
by the structures of the church itself
that's right
will will it provoke anger from the
authorities
well it depends how much our bishops and
our senior priests
have a taste for the kingdom of heaven
but the problem is that these
i'm tempted to call them viciate bishops
and clergy who are so
actively cooperating with governments
all over the world and
shutting down acts of worship don't
actually think that they're suppressing
the gospel they do
genuinely think in a misguided way that
they're doing the right
thing and that in a way is what makes
the situation so
deadly oh yes you're absolutely right
now i like the
term viciaite and rice kierke is the
equivalent from the german historical
context
well i think the last time we talked i i
apologized for saying that
christianity was substantially gnostic
and we're back there again
there is a born from aboveness there is
a literacy of the holy spirit
which if you don't have you can't
understand
where the wind is blowing from and where
it's going to and what is
what its effect is supposed to be you
know it's just a fact of life that
within an organization like the church
you you will have and have always had
people who get the spiritual
authenticity and
people who don't and actually sometimes
you know something we're not the best
people even to tell the difference
but that doesn't mean we can't say
there's a difference there are two ways
of doing christianity
one works one is faithful one is
congruent with the teaching of jesus
and the other less so one of the
challenges of the crisis
for every generation of christian
is to try to make a distinction between
the two both for ourselves
personally for the key for which is
repentance
and for the church as an organization
which requires a gift of discernment and
sometimes
courage and sometimes sacrifice can we
just finish
by talking about the feelings of anger
that i'm picking up from so many
christians at the moment feelings that
they have been betrayed by their own
hierarchy
i have never known a time when so many
priests speak with such
disdain to put it mildly of
cardinal nichols or their local bishop
depending on
who the bishop is and indeed of the pope
because they see the pope vigorously
cooperating with the genocidal regime
and it's as if a spirit of accommodation
verging on cowardice is stalking
christianity at a time when christianity
is actually being persecuted more
vigorously than it has been for decades
this is really really bad
and i think we need to call out these
bishops
and cardinals and popes
one pope in particular for their
cowardice
yes well i'm not very speaking
personally i'm not very good with anger
i had to resort to
psychotherapy to begin to to get a sense
of how
important it was to learn to handle
anger
creatively and properly and recognize it
for what it is but of course the
spiritual tradition has always been very
clear there are two kinds of anger i
mean
paul says be angry but don't sin there
is a kind of righteous anger
the stakes are high though it requires a
great deal
of perception to be able to tell the
difference between one's personal rage
and frustration
where one's own will to power is
frustrated and and a perfectly
proper anger that we see our lord
expressing
where something beautiful is spoiled
where something
truthful is twisted where something
wonderful is besmirched
and anger is the only proper response
so it takes getting it right but i think
i would say then that this this anger
that you're feeling and picking up
is one of the great signs of hope
because it suggests that people
have seen the situation for what it is
and are responding
with a perfectly proper sense of
frustration and
outrage and disgust the kind of disgust
that blasphemy
real blasphemy produces in us so
the difficulty always is to learn how to
be angry i think in principle
and not to destroy or to wound or to
attack
people and that's a very fine line
indeed and it's particularly problematic
when
we get angry with people who have a
perfectly legitimate command on our
respect
and our obedience and i i think at that
point
it becomes you know very combustible and
everyone needs a very good spiritual
director
it's very very difficult gavin as you
say
and if you read social media you can see
what you might call righteous anger
mixing with vicious spiteful reactions
to any story that comes along
there is above all i think tremendous
unhappiness
and for that i think the leaders of the
churches
should be held responsible i think that
accountability by
by the bishops and the leaders is part
of the contract of love
that the christian community enters into
because to be a bishop to be a leader in
the church
is to willingly take upon yourself a
responsibility
for the sheep and if you look at the old
testament in particular the
responsibility for those who had
pastoral care for
god's sheep god's children is very high
indeed
i think one of the things one has to say
is the lord will sort it out
ultimately it's his problem and i think
we have to be careful not to compound
confusion and cowardice with our own
anger
as i said i think this is immensely
difficult and i'd be the first person to
say that i
have a lot of trouble every single day
as i read social media
and as one hears different stories and
part of the problem is we don't have a
grasp on all the facts
on on the truth so all of us our
knowledge is partial and when you have
partial knowledge one has to be very
careful
well perhaps i know this seems a very
melodramatic way of putting it
a constructive response to that anger is
for the church to go
in some senses underground to find a way
of worshiping
in which people are liberated
from bullying bureaucratic bishops
who are essentially behaving like
vandals i
i don't think it's for me to comment on
people's
vows of obedience to their to their
bishops but i'd certainly would say
that where the state begins to make
wholly
improper demands upon the church and
upon the christian conscience
then i think it is entirely legitimate
to consider putting oneself out of the
reach and the sight of the state
in order to maintain one's fidelity to
our lord and the primacy of our
obligations
to god to whom we answer now the extent
to which bishops
side with the state in such a
hypothetical crisis
will of course vary in different
circumstances but in terms of the state
and the christian conscience
there's no doubt in my mind at all that
having to go under crime may very well
as the state ramps up its demands become
increasingly inevitable
i think in the most elegant way you're
sidestepping the question
and i entirely understand why gavin
um we have seen the churches not only
embrace but
expand on the restrictions that have
been placed on them
celebrating the restrictions i think the
bishops
and all the government at least in this
country are
the problem and that does indeed put
christians
in a very very difficult situation
there are bad times coming i think
you're right and if you remember we
agreed
at the beginning of the conversation by
saying that one of the things we didn't
understand
was the way in which the bureaucracy of
the church
seemed to delight in the health and
safety culture that demanded the closure
and the restriction of so much it was
all authentic to the christian
vocation i still don't understand that
perhaps it will become clearer as more
pressure is put on the church
gavin thank you very much and i'm going
to have the last word and say something
that
i don't think you would wish to say or
you're not in a position to say
and that is simply to say to the bishops
you wretched fools can you not see what
you're doing
you